This video is brought to you by Squarespace,
whether it's a new year's resolution or a lifelong passion,
start your journey to website glory with Squarespace,
check out their wonderful all in one platform through the link in the
description below more on them in a bit.
In 1993, Tommy Lee Jones famously gave his speech,
or I listen up ladies and gentlemen,
our fugitive has been on the run for 90 minutes.
Average foot speed over uneven grounds, barring injuries, four miles an hour.
That gives us a radius of six miles.
What I want out of each and every one of you is a hard target search of every
gas station residents, warehouse, farmhouse, hand, house,
out house and dog house in that area, check points go up 15 miles.
Your fugitive's name is Dr. Richard Kimball.
Go get him that is taken from the smash hit movie. The fugitive,
which wedding zones will be nominated for seven Academy awards and became one of
the greatest action films of the 1990s.
It told the story of Dr. Richard kibble played by Harrison Ford,
who was forced to go on the run after being falsely convicted of the murder of
his wife. When in fact the killer had been a mysterious one-armed man,
some fans of the film might be unaware that the fugitive was originally a
television show back in the 1960s.
Even fewer fans may know that the show had been inspired by the sensationalistic
real life murder trial of Dr. Sam shepherd,
who also stood accused of killing his wife.
Just to clarify the creator of the original TV show,
Roy Huggins denied any connection between the two,
although other people involved like the network executive who add the show and
the lawyer in the real case,
both argued that they were definitely related where the Huggins was inspired by
the real trial or not is besides the points,
but it certainly would have been difficult for him not to have been aware of it
because in its day,
there were few other better examples of a media circus than the Sam shepherd
trial.
Even the United States Supreme court to create the proceedings for having a
carnival atmosphere and criticize the media for conducting trial by newspaper
and concluding that Sam shepherd was guilty before it even been brought in for
an interrogation.
So today we're exploring one of the most famous murder cases in American
history. As we examine the death of Marilyn shattered, followed by the arrest,
the trial and the long road to exoneration for her. Husband's Dr. Sam shack.
[Inaudible].
Shepherd was born on December the 29th, 1923 in Cleveland, Ohio,
right from the outset. He seemingly possessed everything.
He needed to lead a successful life. He came from a good family.
He was smart and athletic,
and he was voted most likely to succeed in his senior year of high school.
Once he graduated, he decided to follow in the footsteps of his father,
Richard Allen shepherds, and become a doctor of osteopathic medicine.
So he enrolled at the Los Angeles college of osteopathic physicians and surgeons
just a quick side half and say clarity.
The American medical world makes a clear distinction between doctors of
osteopathic medicine also known as osteopathic physicians and people who are
simply called osteopaths.
The format requires a degree from an approved medical school,
and they're able to practice the same scope of modern medicine as medical
doctors,
which includes performing surgeries and writing prescriptions osteopaths do
not in 1945 shepherd attains his degree in osteopathic medicine and was now Dr.
Sam shepherd DEO for a while.
He stayed in Los Angeles and worked at the County hospital. However, in 1951,
he went back to Ohio to join the family practice.
His father had purchased the Washington Lauren's mansion in Bay village,
affluent suburb of Cleveland,
and turned it into an osteopathic medical center called Bayview hospital during
his time out in Los Angeles, Sam Shepard,
and also married his high school sweetheart in and Reese.
And the couple had already had a young son called Samuel Reese shepherd.
By the time their returns are higher,
they also had a dog called Coco who actually went on to play an important role
during the trial. Nobody had heard the dog barks the night of the crime.
So the prosecution argued that that meant there were no strangers in the house.
Anyway, the point yet is that the shepherd seemed to have a charmed life,
but as was revealed later during the trial all was not well behind closed
doors.
Dr. Shepherd was having an affair with a nurse from his hospital named Susan
Hayes. And according to multiple testimonies,
Marilyn was aware of this by the doctor's own admission.
The couple were having marital troubles.
They intended to work them out and divorce was never really considered,
especially since Marilyn was already pregnant with their second child,
Beginning of July, the third, 1954,
the shepherds were entertaining guests at their house. They were their homes,
family that lived in the neighborhood. After dinner.
The group went to the living room where they started watching the movie strange
holiday on TV. At one point, Sam Shepard fell asleep around midnight.
The Akins went home and Maren and went upstairs to bed.
Letting Sam sleep in the living room. A few hours later,
Marilyn Shepherd was dead after having them brutally bludgeoned in her own bed.
The first person to hear of this was a man called Spencer home,
who was the mayor of Bay village and a friend of the shepherds at around 5:40
AM. He received a distressed call from Sam shepherd to told him for, God's say,
expand, get over here quick. I think they've killed Marilyn hokey.
And his wife were first on the scene,
followed closely by the police who arrived at the shepherd home.
Shortly after 6:00 AM inside the house.
Investigators found a trail of blood leading to Maryland Shepherd's body,
as well as some signs of an apparent robbery.
Seven-year-old Samuel had been sleeping in his room,
unaware of the night's events and an uncle came and picked him up. Meanwhile,
Sam Shepard Senia displayed various cuts and bruises,
which resulted according to him from a fight with a killer whom he described
only as being very bushy head showing signs of shock.
He was sedated and sent to the hospital to get treated for neck injuries back at
the house.
The coroner Dr. Sam gabber arrived at 8:00 AM admins while going over the crime
scene,
he began immediately suspecting shepherd of murdering his wife a few hours
later. Police interrogated the osteopathic physician,
according to his version of events.
He woke up during the night after hearing his wife screaming his name.
He rushed upstairs, where he saw a stranger standing over the body of Maryland.
The two fourths bus,
the killer got the upper hand and briefly not shattered on unconscious before
making a run for it. The doctor or woke after a short period,
he went to check on his son who was sleeping in his own room and then ran
outside, looking for the intruder shepherd,
caught up to the killer on the shores of nearby Lake Erie.
They then started brawling again,
but the intruder proved stronger and knock shepherd unconscious. Once more,
by the time the doctor came around the Bush,
he had stranger had stolen his shirt and disappeared.
So shepherd went inside and called Spencer hook.
The police weren't really sold on this story.
There were few signs of a break-in and signed the house.
Nobody else heard or saw the struggle.
And Dr. Shepherd's description of the killer was so vague that at certain
points, he wasn't even sure if it was a man or a woman like doctor go about,
they seem started suspecting Sam shepherd of murdering his wife.
And so he did the newspapers unsurprisingly by the next day,
the death of Marilyn Sheppard was on the front page of every newspaper in
Cleveland. And a few days later in all of the higher cars started lining up.
As people wanted to drive past the infamous shattered house,
less than two weeks after the murder occurred,
the media had already more or less proclaimed Sam Shepard to be guilty.
Things got significantly worse for the doctor during the inquest.
When his relationship with Susan Hayes was brought up,
initially he denied having an affair with that,
but she later fessed up to the whole thing when she was interviewed this not
only proved that shepherd had lied to the police,
but it also gave him a motive for wanting his wife out of the picture.
Once word of this got out the Cleveland's press ran a story with the headline,
why isn't Sam Shepard in jail. And that was on July the 30th,
1954 later that same day police charged and arrested the doctor for the murder
of Marilyn shepherds.
We'll continue with the trial of the century in just a moment.
But before we do just a quick word on behalf of our friends at Squarespace,
it's a new year. So whatever you're thinking about doing well,
it's time to do it with Squarespace. Squarespace is the platform to use.
If you want to get started on that web project that you've been thinking about,
are you looking to get in and out quick without thinking too much about what
your website should look like? Bam,
use one of their quick beautiful templates and make a website that is fresh for
you. Like it's right out of the box.
So maybe you're more of a hands-on person and you have lots of opinions and
ideas about exactly what you want your site to look like. Well,
Squarespace gives you all of the customization options that you get ever ones
with. No updates, no patches, no tactical BS to worry about. Honestly,
setting up your website, tinkering with the design of your seven inclines,
or maybe just playing with the colors.
There are so many extra features that Squarespace provide that will make your
website thrive, maleness, social integrations, analytics, commercial options,
24 seven customer support everything you could ever want in one place. And look,
I've got another channel called mega projects where we did the website for it on
the Squarespace.
It was super easy to set up a beautiful elegant website in no time whatsoever,
also super functional. It's perfect. That's the mega-projects dot net.
If you want to take a look at what is possible with Squarespace,
with someone who has no web skills whatsoever.
So when you're ready to get started on the next project,
if you'll as big or small, if the developers a website, do it with Squarespace,
go to squarespace.com for a free trial. And when you read these launch,
go to squarespace.com forward slash biographics and you'll save 10% off your
first purchase of a website or domain, and let's get back to it.
What followed was one of the most publicized trials in American history,
the preliminary hearing.
It took place in the first half of August after which shepherd was released on
bail on August the 16th. He didn't know it yet,
but that would be the doctor's last day of freedom for almost a decade.
The very next day, the grand jury returns an indictment of first degree murder.
So shepherd was arrested again.
The trial itself started halfway through October after the judge, in the case,
Edward [inaudible] rejected a request from the defense to move the trial out of
Cleveland, due to the extensive publicity. It received years later,
the us Supreme court deemed this a mistake and criticize the judge for failing
to control disruptive influences in the courtroom.
Perhaps the most egregious examples were situations where he did not dismiss the
jury, even though it would have been warranted,
they had not been sequestered and were therefore exposed to sensationalized
radio broadcasts that would have shaped their opinion of Sam shattered.
On one particular occasion, two jurors admitted to listening to a broadcast,
which said that a woman had been arrested in New York claiming that she was the
mistress of Sam shepherd and that they had a child together.
The judge found out about this and allowed the persons do continue serving on
the jury. And worst of all, the claim was later proven to be false.
The prosecution was led by John Mann during the trial.
That was not a lot of actual evidence to indicate that shepherd was the
culprits, the prosecution strategy,
mainly involved using the doctors' affair to establish a motive and pointing out
the inconsistencies in his own flimsy accounts of the events.
As far as shepherd was concerned, he stuck to his original story,
placing the blame on a Bush. He had met the jury retaught on December the 17th.
They deliberated for four days and returned a verdict of guilty of second degree
murder. The judge then sentenced Sam Shepard to life in Brisbane. Meanwhile,
the tragedies kept on coming for the shepherd family Sam's father,
Dr. Richard Allen shepherd was slowly dying of stomach cancer. His mother,
unable to cope with seeing her husband with her in front of her and her son sent
to prison committed suicide on January the seventh, 1955,
his father succumbed to his illness less than two weeks later at the very least
Sam shepherd still had his lawyers fighting for him. His defense attorney,
William Corrigan secured the services of an expert criminologist from California
named Dr. Paul Kirk, who conducted another investigation of the crime scene.
His final report concluded that the killer was left-handed unlike the doctor and
displayed an extreme Patriot of the shepherds.
He found the doctor's version of events to be that expressed his belief that
there was blood in the bedroom that belongs to neither Sam or Marin and shepherd
based on his report, Corrigan filed a motion for a new trial,
but it was dismissed by the eighth district, a higher court of appeals.
A decision later affirmed by the Ohio Supreme court.
[Inaudible] it seems.
It was the end of the road for Sam Shepard.
As the doctor began serving his sentence in a maximum security prison,
but as long as still believed that a short of winning an appeal,
not based on new evidence, but on the prejudice shown against their clients.
During the original trial,
William Corrigan kept fighting for shepherds up until his own death in July,
1961. Afterwards,
his case was taken off the line up and coming at Sandy named F Lee Bailey for
most other lawyers occasions like that,
of Sam Shepard woods undoubtedly represent the highlight of their careers,
but for Bailey, it was just the start.
He would go on to be involved in other high-profile suits,
including the patchy trial, the Boston strangler,
and most famous of all the OJ Simpson case in 1963,
Beatty filed a petition for writ of habeas Corpus in federal court.
On behalf of his clients,
arguing that all the bias publicity against jeopardy violated his right to due
process. Of course, Shepherd's lawyers had already been saying this for years,
but this time Bailey had some new evidence which tainted the presumed
objectivity of the trial. Judge Edward bison,
this involved testimony from people at the courthouse to whom Blethin expressed
his belief, that shepherd was already guilty during the trial law,
before it even started. Most notable of all was crime journalist.
Dorothy Kilgallen who mentioned that judge [inaudible] once called her into his
chambers. And during that conversation regarding shepherd,
the judge said it's an open and shut case.
He's guilty as hell Bailey's petition was accepted in July,
1964 by a federal district court judge Wineman who dismissed the original trial
as a mockery of justice offered almost 10 years in prison. Sam Schatt.
That was a free man.
Once more freedom could have easily been snatched away from him. Again,
habeas Corpus meant that his imprisonments had been ruled to be unlawful.
It did not declare him innocent of his crime and the prosecution had plenty of
time to file a new charges. But even before that,
so they launched an appeal on Wineman's decision, which was approved in 1965,
by the sixth circuit court of appeals,
thus reversing the ruling of the federal judge.
It looks like shepherds would be happy back to prison,
but then Bailey filed his own appeal.
Basically it was a game of one-upmanship until inevitably the case reached the
highest court in the land. The United States Supreme court,
the case of shepherd and Maxwell started in February, 1966.
It ended on June the sixth with a vote of eight to one in the doctor's favor,
the Supreme court under chief justice,
Earl Warren found that the trial judge had failed to protect shepherd
sufficiently from the massive pervasive and prejudicial publicity that
attended his prosecution.
And that the doctor did not receive a fair trial consistent with the due process
clause of the 14th amendments. This was all good news for shampoo,
but once again, this simply invalidated the previous trial.
It did not exonerate him of the murder. The prosecution filed new challenges.
And another trial started in November of that same year. This one, however,
went a little differently.
Bailey was far more aggressive during cross-examination and was able to
discredit some of the previous testimonies for not being objectively
incriminating against his clients. It's only,
it was also able to introduce as evidence, the report from criminologist, Paul,
who expressed his belief that a left-handed third person has been in the
shepherd bedroom on the night of the murder.
And he also avoided putting Sam Shepard on the stand,
knowing that the doctor's a vague story about the bushy had attacker was not
particularly believable.
All of Bailey's hard work paid off and on November the 16th,
the jury found Sam shepherd not guilty of the murder of Meredith.
Shattered.
Finally.
Over 12 years,
Sam Shepard had been officially exonerated of killing his wife now free.
He tried to get his life back on track bond in prison.
He had started communicating with a German divorcee named Arianne Tabin Johan's
and the two got married very soon after his release in 1964.
This was before his second trial and even started.
The marriage did not last very long. However, ending in divorce in 1968,
Tevin Johns claims that shepherd drank a lot and that on occasion he had
threatened her physically, indeed.
Things did not go smoothly for the doctor after his release from prison.
He wanted to stop practicing medicine again,
but he soon discovered that being incarcerated for 10 years had a significant
impact on his skills.
He obtained a position with the Youngstown osteopathic hospital in Youngstown,
Ohio, but was forced to resign in 1968 after making mistakes during surgery.
The cause the deaths of two of his patients,
both here in the hospital faced wrongful death suits,
which made it hard for him to find a position elsewhere.
Following his divorce and his resignation shepherd was struggling with
alcoholism and depression. He moved to a suburb of Columbus.
Gord Gahanna were intended to open a small medical office,
but fate had a different career in mind for him.
Professional wrestling was serious in Gahanna shepherd made the acquaintance of
a man named George Strickland. He was a pro wrestler.
He convinced the doctor that his notoriety,
you could make the hits in wrestling, especially if he played a villain.
Therefore in August, 1969, at the age of 45,
the doctor who had once been accused of murdering his wife had his first pro
wrestling match. Strickland usually acted as his manager or tag partner runs.
He even became Shepherd's father-in-law in real life.
After the doctor married his 20 year old daughter, Colleen Strickland's,
unfortunately Dr. Shepherd's career inside the squad circle lasted less than a
year. His heavy drinking took a toll on his health and on April the sixth,
1970 Sam Shepard died aged 46.
Initially the cause of death was thought to be liver failure,
but it was later determined to be a type of brain damage gold when Nikki and
Kappa Lafayette also a result of his alcoholism.
Since Dr. Sam.
Shepard was found not guilty in a second trial,
this is not the question of well who kills Marilyn Shepherd after his death,
it was his son,
Samuel who continued the fight for justice for both of his parents,
finding his mother's killer and clearing his father's name during the mid 1990s,
Samuel filed suit for wrongful imprisonments against the County.
On behalf of his father.
This led to the exhumation of both shepherds to collect samples for modern DNA
tests, one report, which was used by his lawyer during the trial,
seemingly excluded Sam shepherd as the source of the blood found at the crime
scene. We might not have mentioned him so far,
but the truth is that the long been a viable second suspect that Samuel Shepherd
believed was the real killer.
His name was Richard e-billing and he worked as an occasional handyman in the
neighborhood where the shepherds lipped.
He first came under suspicion in 1959 when he was arrested for Lawson,
as it turns out, eviling stole various items from the houses where he worked,
he had in his possession, some rings,
which have belonged to Marilyn Shepherd while the handyman admissive to
thievery.
He claims that he stole the jewelry years after a death from the house of a
brother-in-law during the original trial,
Liebling was dismissed as a suspect after allegedly passing a polygraph test
with flying colors.
But the modern evaluation claims that the results have been misrepresented and
that they had been inconclusive at best. The same thing,
applied to modern DNA tests. They did not specifically implicate e-billing,
but they also did not rule him out.
And other uncertain aspect was the memorable traits provided by Sam Shepard
regarding his attacker being bushy hat.
Richard e-billing was balding at the time of the crime. He certainly was not,
but she has, but it was also known to wear toupees.
So this two did not conclusively condemn or acquit him decades
later e-billing was sentenced to life in jail for the murder of a different
woman named Sol made Durkin during his incarceration.
Two people came forward claiming that the former handyman had confessed to them
in private that he had murdered Marilyn Shepherd.
One was a woman who used to look off to SMA duck and,
and the other was a fellow inmate. Richard nibbling died in prison in 1998.
So no charges were ever brought against him.
Another even more recent suspect comes to us, courtesy of retired FBI agent,
but at Connors who pointed the finger,
it's a former air force major named James Corp. After his own wife died,
call began committing robberies and Connors believed this.
He burgled the Shepherd's home and attacked Marilyn. When she caught him.
Red-handed ultimately the jury in Samuel Shepherd's wrongful imprisonment suit
sided with the County. It seems that almost half a century later,
many people were still not convinced of Sam Shepherd's innocence.
And that still goes to this day. People write books, articles,
some point the finger at Dr. Shepherd others at Bridget e-billing.
And some believe the murderer may have been a third man at this point in time
with almost everyone involved in the case debt,
it's looking highly unlikely that we'll ever discover the whole truth.
So I really hope you found the video interest.
Please do hit that thumbs up button below. Don't forget to subscribe. Also,
please do support this journey by supporting our fantastic sponsors,
Squarespace, who I'm linking to below. And thank you for watching.